Salut à tous c’est pêcheurs de trésors.
Aujourd’hui on est de retour
dans la carrière abandonnée.
C'est ça, c'est vraiment
un des meilleurs qu'on ait fait.
On a trouvé des centaines de munitions,
des armes, de la dynamite
et surtout la dynamite était
dans des sacs poubelle.
Et là, on est tombé sur quoi ?
Un sac poubelle mort, on va dire,
on va commencer
à vendre sables mouvants.
On va faire un petit pont
à 20.
Mètres plus loin.
Oh putain, ça y est, il aura.
Ça commence.
Bien.
Il est vide. Livide.
On va faire ça, au moins dans l'eau.
Ici, il y a pas mal de déchets,
donc en même temps, on va nettoyer,
on a besoin rempli de plastique. Ouais.
Reprendre nos et c'est parti.
L'eau est assez basse
vu qu'on est en fin d'été.
Il n'y a pas eu encore les pluies.
C'est ça.
On n'a jamais vu l'eau si basse
et ici, on est sur un endroit
qui était inaccessible.
La dernière fois qu'on a pêché ici,
donc, on avait jeté un élément de l'eau.
D'ailleurs, là ou il restait,
et Sydney qui nous regarde.
Mais c'est vrai qu'on devrait pouvoir
lancer un petit peu plus loin.
Il faut être vigilant parce qu'il
y a pas mal de voitures aussi
dans cette carrière.
Surtout au milieu et là bas.
Donc on va essayer de pas non plus
s'accrocher.
Magnéto Way
commence par mort, c'est très moyen,
mais c'est dû au nœud de la corde.
Peut être quelque chose quand même
au poids de la mort ?
Je ne sais pas. Mais moi, ça.
Oui. C'est bon signe.
C'est bon signe.
Il y a des bouts encore.
Alors une cuillère de pêche
surtout.
Et après c'est de la vieille ferraille.
Oui, j'ai quelque chose.
Protoxyde quoi ici ?
C'est incroyable !
Et un bout de moulinet de pêche, c'est
moi. Ici,
on en avait pas de protoxyde ici.
Ça montre que même des jeunes
qui doivent se poser dans le coin.
Mais bon, protos ici,
il faut le faire quand même.
Alors j'ai hâte
quelque chose ? Oui, oui, oui.
Peut être des bois pris des bois
pris dans les avions en train.
Quelque chose. Comme.
Ces nuances nuances de so.
Ah oui. D'époque.
Ça pourrait remplacer le sol ? Oui
bah sympa.
Il reste. Un morceau du sol.
Et des deux côtés.
Oui ok. Belle trouvaille.
Alors regarde,
ça vient du calibre douze.
Oh oui, l'arrière. Oui.
Elle a du se décomposer.
Vu l'état, c'est que c'est de la poudre.
Ça veut dire que c'était peut être
des munitions, pas de la poudre.
Vive ça non ?
Regarde, c'est de la poudre vif.
T'as vu la forme ? Oui, c'est la vieux.
Regardez, l'endroit est quand même joli,
même si ça pue un peu.
Je dois trouver un hameçon,
bien jouer avec la cuillère de pêche.
On commence à avoir du matériel ici,
c'était rempli de munitions
à chaque fois.
Ce qui fut la première munition
à la première.
Mais ici, on paye l'apéro. On a dit.
Au. Vu d'obus, on dirait
Ah non, pas forcément, non.
Alors non, c'est héroïque.
Peut être.
Un bout de.
Quelque. Chose.
Et la finition, c'est ce qui est propre.
Donc l'apéro est pour ma pomme,
ça se diminution.
On voit le marquage de fuite
à quatre.
C'était des Françaises, un carré ici
surtout, mais là, elle paraît plus
propre.
Neuf cnf,
le calibre,
c'est un peu même
vent, c'est pas sympa.
Dites nous en commentaire
ce que vous en pensez ?
Une première trouvaille sympa.
Bien joué.
Nerveux, c'est bon signe.
Il en reste un oui,
oui, oui, oui, oui, oui.
Bravo.
Deuxième partager.
J'ai eu chaud pour l'apéro, c'est peu.
Je crois
qu'on est exactement sur la même.
Hop, c'est les mêmes et ça, c'est
super ancien, ça doit venir.
N'est ce pas ce que Romain
il a trouvé dans son terrain ?
Presque.
Ça ressemble
à de volley ball avec un crochet.
Un. Sympa.
Sais en quelque chose aussi là.
Ou une.
Autre prend un coup.
Comme elles sont alignées.
Les imposé.
Très sympa,
j'en suis à quatre, je prends le large.
Bravo !
Peut être que des algues si c'est si
grave. d'Elles.
Bien joué. Cool !
Un anneau gastrique.
Classique, c'est sympa, ça commence
bien.
Moi j'aime bien pour un sport
déjà fait, c'est cool.
Allez, on continue.
J'arrête quelque chose.
Ici. Les algues ? Oui.
Sinon oui.
Bien joué. La main genou, c'est la même.
La mouche.
En cas. Allez
vous en pensez quoi ?
Les chiens ?
Je vais peut être un truc là bas.
Je remonte vite pour pas que ça
frotte trop dans les rochers.
Ouais, ouais, ouais.
Une autre et alors ?
De pêche,
il est foutu, mais c'est un gros.
Et j'en suis à cinq.
Oh oui.
Bien joué !
Et pourtant, je suis. Juste là
pour faire ouf !
Oh, des clés !
Un trousseau de clés en plus,
une en laiton et d'autres en fer.
J'ai tout un trousseau. Ici.
Et ici aussi.
Alors donne un coup.
Donc effectivement,
les munitions, c'est là.
Parce que ces.
Munitions en échoppe, mais en tirant là,
là et là, il y en a partout ici parce.
Qu'il y en a.
Oh oui.
Un bonheur de pêche.
Il a de très beaux yeux.
Après,
tu as 1 h de pêche.
Sydney ?
Oh oui, oui, ont attrapé ça.
C'était un piège à poissons,
alors il faut l'enlever.
Bouteilles plastiques. Là.
Je sais, je
sais.
Dur à attraper si.
Je jette.
Je l'ai presque.
C'est bon.
Oh là là, on meurt les écrevisses.
Ah oui,
bon, bon, on va le garder.
Hein ?
Pour faire nos pièges à écrevisses,
bien sûr.
Bon, j'ai quelque chose.
Ah ah ! Ah !
J'ai cru. Oh ! Beaussire ! Oh !
Ça, c'est le morceau de corde de pas
seulement.
Aïe ! Aïe ! Aïe ! Aïe, aïe.
Il y a eu un drame dans le coin,
je pense.
Non, non,
encore un l'heure de pêche pour rien.
C'est au nom.
De ce Baptiste. Bref.
À une bête là.
Puis je fais très bien. Le chien
aboie apres avoir regardé.
Oh oui, le film est une buse blanche
lui aussi, mais
il n'a pas vu la blouse blanche.
Je l'ai vu à peine autour de.
Moi et sur les rastas.
OK, quand on vient de remonter
un sac plastique ou quelque chose
dans du plastique
à droite, un vrai sac plastique.
C'est un truc de frigo.
Ah oui, c'est
un tiroir de frigo qui avait été réparé
et. Ça.
Vite. OK,
alors en ce qui concerne les aimants,
on utilise avec Quentin les Barbarian
de chez maison de la détection.
Donc c'est cela.
Et regardez ça,
il n'y a pas mieux comme sponsor.
Voilà le barbarian, ce qu'il arrive
à trouver en étant tiré juste là.
Donc trois munitions,
1600 kilos de force et on a John
qui est avec nous aujourd'hui
et Jade elle utilise le Matterhorn
qui est pas mal aussi et qui fait le taf
puisque dans les algues
ils arrivent à remonter ça.
Le terror c'est 1200
kilos et c'est celui qu'on conseille
en général pour débuter.
Il fait un job. Voilà,
il est validé aussi.
Vous avez le code promo
Pêcheur de trésor qui s'affiche
ici au moins cinq pour 100
sur toute la boutique,
y compris sur les détecteurs de métaux.
Alors regarder ça, c'est
des obus.
Ouais, c'est des obus antiaériens.
Ouais, vide. Heureusement,
en fait il avait des têtes en aluminium
qui se visse.
Il a la tête que lui et la tête, c'est
un voilier,
donc il n'est pas si vite que ça.
Il est facile et creux là,
mais il y a la tête qui est encore là.
Donc il y a peut être une petite charge,
la tête aussi quand même,
puisque c'est
la détonation qui se fait là.
Et puis vous avez la poudre ici,
donc attention, mais bon,
ça reste tout petit. Obus
de dépollution quand même.
C'est bien de sortir, aller chercher
d'autres.
OK, encore une.
Et tu vois, j'étais sur un clip.
Oui, il y a un morceau du clip,
ça va être une sacrée arme
qui tire des munitions comme ça.
Une de plus juste ici
donc sûrement une caisse de munitions
qui est en train de se décomposer.
Et non pas.
Un oui, une cuillère de pêche encore.
Là bas.
En fait, du matériel de pêche,
un morceau, du gros boum
et ça a peut être donné des indices.
Ouais, ouais, ouais ouais.
Je dis le bout de plaque là dessus.
Des morceaux de vieilles ferrailles,
ça pourrait être la casse.
Mais c'est vrai que les munitions,
il y en avait quand même
plus la première fois,
il y avait des fois
ou on remonte l'élément
avec une vingtaine dessus.
C'était des vrais de munitions.
On peut dire qu'il
y a une quantité énorme de munitions
qui ne sont pas aimantées.
Ouais, c'est ça. C'est ça le truc.
Je viens de faire une lame de couteau
cassé.
Intéressant.
Un couteau suisse.
Bien pointu.
Un couteau qui a été visé à la main.
Quelle est la première remontée
du cousin
en direct ?
Aïe, aïe, aïe ! On l'a vu sauter.
Pas grand chose, mais il y a peut être
des munitions. On sait jamais
si c'est une scie, s'il
y en a. Moi
aussi,
une seule,
de gros morceaux de cuivre.
Comme elle était attachée à le clip
qui est là,
c'était des bandes
avec plusieurs objets.
Chacun y a joué
exactement fait la balle,
alors on est encore sur la revanche.
Et quand un envoyé du lourd
puisqu'il a fait
deux munitions classiques
les mêmes donne 45 rcp.
Note de 45.
On en est faite par ici. Ouais,
très peu.
C'est la position des Colt 1911
et des Thomson et des Thomson
dans la seconde guerre mondiale.
Sûrement on regardera le culot,
mais c'est cool le grappin,
tu fais des choses différentes
et là encore utilisable.
Même plutôt.
Si. Quentin pour la salle de bain.
De pointe. Ah ouais. Effectivement.
J'ai chez moi la vie.
Ouais, je n'avais pas.
Ouais, mais c'est bien la France.
J'avais repêché
mes lunettes dans pas longtemps.
Ah oui.
Oh. Mon que ça ressemble à une caisse
de munitions, c'est possible.
Peut être qu'elle est enfin comme ça
qu'elle a enfin sorti.
En tout cas, c'est très ancien.
C'était troué d'origine.
Les pros nous diront peut être.
Oh, j'ai quelque chose à accrocher
avec la barbe.
J'ai du cuivre
à petites bobines de cuivre.
Pas trop fort.
On avait une caravane, un cheval.
Deux choses. Tordues.
Un cheval tordu et une belle munition.
Mais faut le faire pour un fer à cheval
comme ça, c'est étonnant.
Super solide.
Normalement
dans les bras,
il faut qu'il soit plus incroyable.
Bah ouais.
Normalement c'est hyper solide.
Bah ouais mais il m'a tendu le bizarre
parce qu'il est percé sur ça.
Votre porte chance ?
Oui. Un anneau gastrique.
Je découvre un anneau ici.
Un anneau gastrique vient jouer un. Peu.
À. Du plastique.
Peut être tu peux faire des sacs
avec des munitions, quoi ?
On en a déjà fait.
Il y a quelque chose dans son sac.
Après ça,
faut faire l'ouverture en vidéo. Non,
pas, ça pue, ça peut pas.
Il joue.
Il arrive rien.
De plus énormément.
Il y a des choses.
Mais c'est une bonne façon.
C'est bizarre, c'est des papiers un peu.
Je crois que c'était de la dynamite.
Eh ouais.
C'est les cartons
comme les bâtons de dynamite,
mais du coup,
on va vous mettre des images.
J'ai trouvé des bâtons de dynamite
en meilleur état ici,
mais c'est clairement les mêmes.
Belle trouvaille. Job.
Merci bien merci bien.
Oh une corde !
Un non, c'est pas du filet de.
Un point dans un caoutchouc.
Il a cassé ?
Non mieux.
T'as pas vu derrière quoi ?
Oui, à première.
Vue, ça y est. Bravo !
On a tous vu ça.
On a jamais. Vu une écoute pour.
Lui raconter que j'ai fait ça. Non.
Non, surtout
faut pas tomber sur tout ça.
C'est juste que ça se bien.
On va se forcer le vendredi. Comme.
On est de retour au même endroit.
Apprendre c'est bien, mais je ramasse.
Bottes. A fait quelques trucs sympa.
On va au mur.
Oula oui
oh ça va les différentes, non ?
Et c'est la même.
Et elle est creuse.
On dirait que la poudre s'est échappée,
mais c'est
celle qui a encore de l'air dedans.
Si ça fait ça, non ?
Ben oui. Il a l'air bien massif.
Il est trempé,
ce qui est lourd. Les roues
qui sortent une corde en dessous et.
Tu veux le ramener
pour avoir bu de l'eau.
Avant ?
En plus, je crois que vous.
Il reste vachement
de choses en dessous de l'arbre.
Il y a.
Un leurre de pêche grenouille,
il y a du calibre douze,
il y a une munition, il y a la caisse
des munitions, c'est sûr.
Maintenant que ça va, le reste des.
Boulons.
C'est incroyable
parce que si on vire l'arbre de dessus,
il y a des trucs comme ça.
Ça va faire ça.
Les Plaines.
Ça, ça.
C'est pas du douze, c'est plus petit,
mais bon, ça reste pour la chasse,
ça. Sympa.
Franchement, il est très stylé
ce grenouille.
Pour un ça. Passage.
Tu te baignes avec la.
Tu crois que tu enlèves l'hameçon
dans la gorge ?
Absolument.
Il y a plein de bateaux de pêche
des gorges.
Alors d'accord.
Tu veux, mais il est mort.
Non, non merci.
Encore une fois, bravo.
S'il a le soutien.
D'un enfant qui s'amuse avec l'arbre.
Oh sympa ça.
Ça fait bien que ça se casse pas.
Ce que faire.
Alors là,
on se sent sûr.
Il y a un liquide dedans.
Et c'est étanche
complètement.
Ça en fait.
Un débutant.
Ça vous inspire. Pas
à bien jouer, alors ça va.
Tu veux boire ?
Moi, je pense qu'il
faudrait boire ta trouvaille.
C'est bizarre.
Mais j'aime bien
la petite nous aux commentaires.
Si vous savez ce que c'est
que de le fermer, pour l'instant
je pense, on demande aux abonnés d'abord
et selon ce que si on l'ouvre en l'ouvre
pas comme ça,
on ne fait pas de bêtises,
il faut m'éviter.
Donc en tout cas, c'est avec toi.
C'est ma préférée
là pour l'instant. Vachement.
Très sympa.
Ecoute et là au grappin, franchement,
il y a moyen de faire des trucs
parce qu'empêcher tout le temps
de là bas
et on a ramené plein de trucs
pas trop remontés.
Mais bon, c'est vrai
qu'il y a des algues aussi.
Oui, mission ça faisait longtemps.
Oh et ça,
c'est de la vieille ferronnerie aussi.
Un peu forget.
C'est ancien, c'est sympa
à vide ou plein
à abattant. Nous, ça arrive.
Un sac, un sac, un sac.
Te laisse l'ouvrir.
Le cousin qui a trouvé un objet
dans un sac
grâce au grappin,
ça peut tout et n'importe quoi.
Je l'ai pris dans l'avancement.
Ouais, c'est ouvert, c'est lesté.
Du coup,
ça c'est quelque chose de lesté,
ce qui reste pas
des eaux de choses comme ça.
Dommage.
Le saint qui s'est ouvert ainsi.
Sinon ça c'est quoi ça ?
C'est des eaux.
Si c'est des eaux, ça
regarde.
C'est clairement des petits oiseaux.
Sauf un crâne
de nounours
qui ont été envoyés là dedans.
Ouais
ouais, il est tout petit au
trop bon.
Pas fou comme trouvaille, mais bon.
Plus un.
Le produit vapeur là.
Bas, c'est un.
Nouveau sac.
Alors oui, ça c'est vrai
que c'est exactement
la même.
Ouais, pour valider ça
entre deux vidéos,
cela devient un beau sapin de jeunesse.
Il y a un autre sac dans le sac,
c'est Montigny.
Oh, des munitions, c'est rempli
de munitions, c'est plein, plein, plein.
On regarde,
elles sont présentées en attendant.
Ohlala, il y a peut être une arme avec ?
Non, c'est. Remplir.
Oh, la quantité ! Oh
oh incroyable.
Dinguerie !
Regardez tout ce qu'il y a.
C'est hallucinant.
On regarde.
Ah ouais.
C'est du 45 assez peu
spécial.
En réponse.
Ah oui, 38
quelques centaines de quantité.
La la.
Super trouvaille.
Et c'est ce que je désire.
Même placer dans cet état, ça.
Remplit en réalité rien.
Il y en a pas beaucoup celle là.
Vous êtes souvent plus à nous dire
en commentaire.
Utiliser des grappin.
Voilà le cousin du grappin
pour avoir au moins une trouvaille.
T'as la meilleure trouvaille
de la journée.
Pour l'instant, ça dépend
ce qu'il a trouvé, je sais pas quoi.
De toute façon,
on a vu un sac, un sac dans un sac.
C'est très bon signe
à chaque fois. Ouais.
Ouais, c'est du plomb.
Je vois clairement
que c'est du Plan. Nord.
Si j'avais pu l'avoir sans portrait.
Ouais, hum.
C'est peut être un bon truc là.
Pour le coup, aïe aïe aïe.
C'est une branche.
OK, ça commence à devenir short ici.
Long, ça va déclencher Sidney.
Il y a un canard, qu'il y a un hameçon
dans la bouche, on dirait.
C'est le plus clair.
On va essayer
de l'attraper, de l'enlever.
Mais ça a l'air très dur
d'attraper un canard.
Surtout que ça a l'air
d'être le plus craintif.
Comme par hasard.
Mais Jade est une professionnelle.
Ils sont un peu bêtes en plus, ces.
Gamins, pas
à c'est
un échec.
Ah ouais.
On était loin, je crois.
Bon, bah tant pis.
Je pense que c'est
une mission qui a échoué.
Mais on aura essayé. Ouais.
Un Baptiste aura essayé.
Elle est bonne
sa santé.
C'était l'occasion.
Pour moi. Donc
tant pis.
Là, on a changé de spot,
on est en face de la falaise.
Eh oui, Job a quelque chose déjà
que donc.
La ferraille.
De la ferraille ?
OK, il y a des choses déjà bon signe.
Oh ouais, c'est profond ici.
OK, Romain, un truc lourd.
Tu ne veux pas tirer
en dessous de la falaise ?
Si ça lâche, putain, ça soulève.
Pardon pour le gros mot.
C'est pas ça encore, même si.
Le poids, c'est vrai, c'est aussi
tu fais vachement de bulles.
Ah ouais, je me fais chier ça.
Je sais bien que
j'ai dit oui.
C'est quand même dangereux, mais oui,
c'est lacrymos.
J'ai quitté les lieux
délicatement. Bien joué.
C'est écrit dans la référence dessus
ce qui vient de trouver notre cousin.
Donc ça peut être dangereux.
Je pense que c'est une grenade à gaz
lacrymo.
Ça va pas mal. Trouvaille.
Bien joué, mais faut aussi
surtout quand même pas s'amuser avec.
Pouvoir regarder avec la référence,
non ?
Vous affichera ce que c'est.
Sympa de jouer.
Content que vous n'ayez pas
filmé ce jeu.
Oh pardon, c'est le principal.
Un bout de pot
d'échappement, peut être ?
Voilà, je pense.
Maintenant, c'est fermé.
Il y a un bouchon,
un bouchon, ça se dévisse.
Ouais, alors ça peut être une trappe
à essence si elle va loin dedans.
Sur un véhicule un peu bizarre, tu sais,
regarde le bouchon,
il fait un peu trappe à essence.
Ouais, c'est vrai.
Mais si profonde de mon commentaire.
À quel véhicule ça peut appartenir
si c'est ça d'ailleurs.
Mais le bouchon me fait penser.
À. De 45 à pieds comme je l'ai fait.
Donc ça, oui, c'est ça.
Munitions de Colt 1911,
première seconde guerre mondiale.
Et regarde le 42 que tu vois,
ça veut dire 1942. OK.
Donc ça va vraiment bien conserver. Oui.
Parce que ça nous a frappé encore.
Ouais, ouais.
Ouais,
un morceau de scooter, ça je pense,
c'est un indice.
Oui, avec la durite.
Ça, c'est une pièce de scooter,
c'est sur un scooter.
Si vous pouvez nous dire ce que c'est,
un commentaire.
Waw, une suspension
ça c'est vieux. Ça.
Se vieux.
Et ça c'est une très vieille
suspension aussi.
OK c'est sympa.
Mais solution.
Pas d'emploi pas.
Loin.
C'est en deux.
Roues, ça fait coque, je te jure.
Il a touché le fond,
il s'est mis sur un truc
en plein
milieu, en plein milieu, là bas.
Pour qui ?
Tout de suite.
Ouais quand même. Quelque chose.
Ne ferait
dans vous.
Intéressant
parce que c'est la.
Question du fil accroché dessus. Bon.
Ça n'inspire pas énormément confiance.
Dans.
Sans commentaires.
Est ce que c'est une histoire de chose ?
Un point intéressant. Enfin,
si je le perd pas dans les rochers,
ça va être très sympa
parce que c'est un cadre.
On voit bien
au est ce que c'est.
Oui. Le nom,
il est beau,
celui là, c'est du costaud, voire.
Je suis content, c'est bon signe ça.
L'outil du cambrioleur.
Il est incroyable. Un bon état en plus.
Comme quoi il peut rester des armes.
C'est une arme de meurtre.
Déjà, ça va chopper ça, c'est
qu'il peut rester du lourd,
le machin massif constatant pas mort.
Qu'est ce que c'est que ce travail ?
Oui oula, encore un nouveau type,
ça c'est du CAC40, ça ça rigole pas,
on regarde.
Mais je crois que c'est du hacking
sans saveur.
Alors c'est
quoi la différence entre les deux ?
À la forme ?
Ouais, mais pourquoi cette formule ?
C'est savoir faire semblant ? T'as
pas d'ogives ?
OK, d'accord.
Et là, c'est noué l'appareil.
Et ça, c'est notre côté Famas.
47, je crois.
Quand t'as 65 56 ans, c'est ça ?
C'est Famas, calibre OTAN.
Ça ça rigole pas.
Et des munitions de tendance récente
à 100. Bonnetain, ça aussi ça fait 26.
Ce prix années 90, c'est.
Quatre 20. Six.
C'est calibre OTAN.
88 sont bien quand ça vient.
Ça, c'est ça va quoi ? C'est sympa.
Trop de munitions restantes quand même.
C'est considéré que ça.
Prend le sens
pour dire 350.
Trois, c'est 22 fois.
Oui. Oui, c'est ça.
Deux fois oui.
Ça monte, ça vient, ça vient, ça vient.
Ouais, y'a un truc qui vient.
Enfin la frontière, non ?
Un cadre moche dans un cadre
qu'on le perde. Bon, on dirait qu'on n'a
pas tout.
Mais une mobylette,
peut être un cadre de moto
au milieu de passants romains
qui remonte de là bas.
Quand on voit qu'il
y a de la profondeur, de souffle
en profondeur, on est bien accroché.
À ça et c'est le siège auto.
Qu'il y a derrière.
Enfin,
on s'en doutait qu'il y en avait là.
Ils ont laissé quelques plastiques.
Ouais, ça fait un moment qu'il est là.
Il y a encore le feu arrière
et clignotant,
heureux de jouer enfin voilà.
C'est quoi terrain ?
C'est le réservoir.
Comme il était bloqué les mains pour ça,
il pensait qu'il
y avait de l'essence dans le réservoir
parfaitement dedans.
Et oui,
pour ça, l'essence, ça explique tout.
Tu vois,
toute l'essence, on a réussi
à en sauver quand même.
C'est pour ça
qu'il ne reste d'ou les taches.
On va enfin on l'a sorti de l'eau, cela
bien joué.
Merci.
C'était ça depuis le début
qu'il y en avait plein.
Qu'est ce que tu nous a fait de beau ?
Ecoute un magnifique lors de pêche.
Franchement, il est correct celui là,
il a une jolie couleur et en même temps
voilà les hameçons.
Bravo, belle trouvaille. Merci.
Ah ouais.
C'est un terror on dirait.
Alors tout de même.
Que moi. Ça ça intéressant.
Moi c'est mieux que toi c'est bien.
Alors va t'en.
Mais encore faudrait cette fin de boucle
pour rattraper autour de neuf.
Ce qui est étonnant,
c'est que d'habitude quand on perd
un aimant, c'est l'autre coté
qui est accroché.
Je sais pas comment il s'est débrouillé,
mais il faut qu'on
garde les deux bouts de la corde.
Peut être que.
Ça va pas, ça va se tirer.
Saturation une allumette de plus.
De mon côté, le.
Président n'est pas loin.
C'est sûr, je m'étais lavé pour Noël.
Oh oui, oui, c'est bon.
On attend maintenant. Stop là.
Certains côtés, c'est pas si.
Tiens,
un petit film qui j'aime.
Vous avez la nouvelle façon de l'ONU ?
Enfin. Au moins.
Il vient de 60. Quinze.
Euros, c'est qu'il est pro là.
Attention, c'est pas fini, c'est
pas fini.
Précisément les galets.
Au pompier, on coupe la corde.
Au plus tard.
Ah oui, c'est un plus petit, c'est
pas un terroriste, on l'attend.
C'est lourd, parce qu'en fait, c'est
un crochet dans un truc.
La corde sur sa bulle, là.
Mais comment
ils ont trempé quelque chose ?
Il doit y avoir un entrainement ou
un grappin de l'autre côté, une corde.
Il doit avoir un grappin.
Moi, je parie sur un grappin, sur loupé.
Il avait un
aimant et un grand pas de l'autre côté.
J'attends
d'ailleurs que ça se fasse pas.
Ah oui, ce serait marrant
de voir ce qu'il y a au bout.
Ah bon, on va voir
sous l'eau ?
J'ai pas Megan
aller pour tirer sur
la foule.
Mère.
Je viens de pas tomber.
Et un truc a lâché.
Pour pourquoi c'est
pas ça ?
C'est un arbre, non ?
Non, mais un grappin.
Non, je pense pas.
Je pense que c'était que la corde
posée dans l'eau.
Ils ont travaillé une double corde,
ils ont doublé.
Plutôt que suivant.
Non ?
Je pense qu'elle est doublée.
Ils avaient du galérer vraiment pour.
C'est un aimant de magnétosphère,
mais dans la détection tout neuf,
c'est un ISIS je pense.
On donne aux cousins entre le terroir
et le.
Ici c'est plus vous laisse.
Vous le.
Faire depuis pour les filles
vous le serait pas pour les débutants.
On j'accompagne
Antonov. Il a fait bien plus
que les CPU.
En même temps, c'est.
Petit mais. Puissant.
Et si vous,
si vous reconnaissez votre mot
envoyé,
envoyez nous un petit message privé.
On va trouver,
on va trouver un arrangement.
Et si vous voulez faire semblant
que c'est le vôtre,
envoyez quand même un message privé.
Vous vous postez ensuite avec. Votre.
Commentaire un commentaire assez
de messages privés, aucun commentaire.
C'est un aimant encore.
Donc vous les trouverez
sur le site de maisons de détection.
Je pense pas que ce soit le ISIS,
donc c'est déjà pas mal.
Déjà regarde, c'est déjà
pas mal pour débuter en soi.
Surtout qu'il aurait perdu un bon bah
si il avait été au bar ici.
Allez, on.
Vous tiendrai au courant
des découvertes de Romain.
J'essaye tout de suite. Si
tu as le goût,
il est attaché, il.
Serait mal finir et se bloquer direct.
En maudit.
Il y a un garde en provenance
alors
ça va.
Mais voilà, c'est
la fin de cette vidéo de pêche.
Finalement pour nous,
on est revenu sur ce spot.
On vous a dit qu'il
restait surement des choses.
C'est vrai, il en restait
mais franchement, on s'est éclaté
une journée très sportive.
N'hésitez pas à nous dire en commentaire
si vous êtes déjà venu ici sans dire
l'endroit comme ça,
on ramène pas encore plus de monde.
N'hésitez pas à nous dire
si vous êtes déjà venu à nous,
on verra tout là bas. Nous, on viendra.
Peut être qu'on peut
se faire une session ici tous les ans.
Ça peut être sympa de voir
si ce lieu va être enfin propre un jour.
En tout cas
une quantité folle de plastique.
On a un sachet poubelle rempli
et de munitions aussi est toujours
comme d'hab.
On déposera tout ça en gendarmerie
et on vous dira la semaine prochaine
pour une nouvelle vidéo prochainement.